on parle beaucoup de points loeb mais
j'ai fait moi-même la vérification puis
on peut facilement trouver sur un paquet
d'autres plateformes de la pornographie
juvénile en quelques minutes ce point
défilent alors il faut il faut agir
ottawa promet de s'attaquer à la
pornographie juvénile sur le web
notamment sur le site pornhub le
ministre du patrimoine réagissait ainsi
à une enquête bouleversante du new york
times qui a révélé que ce géant de la
pornographie enregistré à montréal
permet la diffusion de vidéos de viol
une exploitation sexuelle de mineurs
mastercard et visa ont ouvert des
enquêtes sur ces allégations et pourrait
cesser leur collaboration avec ce site
qui reçoit à lui seul plus de 3
milliards de visites par mois
c'est un des sites les plus visités dans
le monde je reçois la sénatrice
indépendante julie miville de chêne qui
demandent depuis plusieurs mois déjà au
gouvernement des mesures pour sévir
contre paume là même proposé dans un
projet de loi privé de bloquer l'accès à
la pornographie aux moins de 18 ans j'ai
une ville de chelles bonsoir bonsoir
votre réaction d'abord à ce projet de
loi du ministre steven guilbeault qui
veut mettre en place un régulateur qui
veulent surveiller donc ce genre
d'entreprise il y mettra la main à nos
besoins exacts alors c'est assez
ambitieux parce que le ministre guilbaud
ne veut pas seulement mettre au pas les
sites pour nommer les plateformes web
sur plusieurs points sur l'exploitation
sexuelle des enfants mais aussi sur le
discours haineux sur l'incitation la
province à la violence mais ce qui est
remarquable madame galipeau sait à quel
point on constate la toute puissance du
new york times est le seul fait d'avoir
interpellé justin trudeau d'avoir
rappelé son acte de foi féministe et
d'avoir posé cette question comment le
canada peut-il héberger un site qui
présente des vidéos de viol au monde
entier donc steven guilbeault doit agir
it pour corriger la réputation du canada
et vous l'avez dit l'idée de ce
régulateur ce sera de s'assurer que les
plateformes retirons le plus vite
possible les vidéos idéal et vidéos
illégales qui s'y trouvent donc vous le
voyez c'est assez ambitieux mais est ce
que ça peut régler le problème parce
qu'on parlait de ce reportage du new
times sa brise le coeur vraiment cédé
vie de jeune fille brisé conquis qu'on
nous raconte
et on se demande comment donc une
compagnie comme celle-là peut encore
opéré au canada alors certainement ça ne
règle pas tout le problème parce que on
ici ce sont des citoyens qui
téléchargent ces vidéos amateurs sur le
site de pornhub et les autres donc on va
continuer à télécharger ces vidéos qui
contiennent parfois de l'exploitation
sexuelle de mineurs et ce n'est qu'une
journée deux journées trois journées
plus tard alors que des milliers
personnes auront déjà vu ces vidéos
qu'on l'ait retiré
ça veut dire que des vies de jeunes
filles vont continuer à être brisé aussi
je vous rappelle que les sites pornos
font de l'argent non seulement avec ses
vidéos de mineure mais avec des vidéos
montrant de la violence avec des femmes
inconscientes apparemment asphyxié donc
il ya toutes sortes de choses sur
pornhub qui ne sont pas forcément
touchés par cette nouvelle loi qui
devrait arriver assez rapidement c'est
aussi ça le défi du ministre guilbaud
roux parle d'une loi en janvier et en
février
alors ça c'est rapide en ce moment ouais
mais est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire et ce qu'il faut exiger de
l'entreprise parce qu'on le disait ainsi
que c'est comme le youtube de la
pornographie prod ne produit pas de
vidéo mais met en ligne les vidéos que
les gens envoient alors est-ce qu'il
faut exiger de cette entreprise quelle
qu'elle qu'elle obtienne un consentement
en fait parce que c'est ça qui est le
problème c'est que ces vidéos l'a
souvent ces jeunes filles elles se
retrouvent sur port noble sans avoir
jamais consenti exactement alors
évidemment quand on est mineur la
question n'est pas de consentir
mais on n'a pas le droit de présenter de
la pornographie juvénile ça c'est
illégal mais vous avez raison de dire
que
modèle où tout ne fonctionne pas à mon
avis quand on parle de pornographie
parce que justement le consentement
d'une femme d'un homme à la
participation des activités sexuelles
d'étape seulement pas vérifié par power
up quand les vidéos sont téléchargées
donc ce n'est que plus tard quand
quelqu'un se plaint que on peut
constater qu'il ya pas eu consentement
donc c'est très difficile légalement il
faut le dire de demander à des
compagnies d'obtenir le consentement de
vérifier l'âge avant de télécharger ses
vidéos mais je dois vous dire que je
considère que pour loeb devrait être
imputables responsable c'est elle qui a
choisi ce modèle d'affaires pourquoi les
pelles n'est-elle pas davantage à
l'écouté des dérives de ce modèle
surtout que c'est extrêmement difficile
selon selon ce qu'on lit de se
débarrasser de ceux de faire alors
paraître ces vidéos tout à fait des
jeunes filles de 14 ans qui revoit des
années plus tard des vidéos d'elle sur
ces sites parce qu'il faut comprendre
que plusieurs sites vidéo mais points
loeb en particulier permet à ses clients
de télécharger ses vidéos où certains
complètement illégal sur leur propre
ordinateur donc ces vidéos continuent à
exister même si on les supprime sur un
site et continuer à être diffusés
partout dans le web donc c'est une
espèce d'araignée c'est extrêmement
difficile et comme je vous le dis les
les
l'enquète du new york times était
formidable parce qu'elle nous montrait
une jeune fille
on avait son nom et on voyait comment sa
vie avait été brisée elle avait commencé
à prendre de la drogue
elle avait fait une tentative de suicide
lâcher l'école et elle s'étaient revus
petit misé en revendant son corps plus
tard à 16 ans elle avait commencé à 14
ans à être abusé par un homme
donc ce sont des gis littéralement brisé
et on va voir ce que le canada fait
c'est quand même ambitieux parce qu'il
ya très peu de pays qui interviennent
sur ces questions-là l'australie est en
avance mais le canada va donc faire une
tentative pour mettre au pas les
plateformes ou alors vous dites il faut
agir il faut agir vite
oui ben ali
absolument merci beaucoup j'ai lu ville
aux jeunes